by now you're well aware of the many
deadly threats facing law in her quest
to uncover the secret of immortality and
you've learned about the importance of
choice in combat tactics upgrades and
skills
in this final episode we'll be focusing
on tunes and the advanced reversal
abilities Laura uses to both explore and
survive them
this is woman vs wild dooms provide Lara
with exciting new opportunities to
explore collect artifacts and uncover
important historic details utilizing a
new translation system Lara can learn
new languages and delve deeper into
mysteries from the past by examining
murals ancient scrolls and other
markings in world Lara can improve her
proficiency in three distinct languages
once she reaches the required level she
can begin translating mysterious
monoliths which reveal the locations of
buried treasures and secret crypts of
course accessing the important areas of
each tomb won't be easy puzzles often
stand between Laura and her goal with
deadly traps and dangerous passageways
adding to the challenge
lara must always remain aware of the
physical properties of play all around
her many puzzles involve natural
elements and Lara's ability to combine
and manipulate wind water and fire will
prove critical in overcoming these
obstacles rise of the Tomb Raider
features a number of nested puzzles
which can only be solved by overcoming a
series of challenges that each
contribute to the solution these puzzles
span areas so large that Lara must often
engage in traversal and combat in
between segments making tombs feel
massive ancient and deadly
because optional challenge tombs appear
off the critical path they feature
exotic themes more challenging puzzles
and some breathtaking views when
overwhelmed by these environments Lara
can use survival instincts to gather her
bearings identify critical elements and
better grasp the unique mechanisms
housed within these massive spaces can
prove daunting but by using advanced
traversal lightning-fast reflexes and
clever thinking Lara can uncover their
most well-guarded sequence with great
risk comes great reward and the treasure
that Lara uncovers in each of these
challenge teams will unlock an ancient
ability such as firing two arrows in
quick succession without needing to
reach into her equipment once learned
Lara can use these skills throughout her
journey to become an even more capable
adventurer rise of the Tomb Raider is
filled with breathtaking main tunes
devious challenge tombs and
claustrophobic crypts each filled with
artifacts pews and untold secrets
waiting to be discovered
this brings us to the end of our
three-part series we hope you've enjoyed
this look at lara's adventure in rise of
the tumor Ashima survive in harsh
environments utilized guerrilla combat
tactics to even the odds against trinity
and use her skills and wits to unlock
the mysteries of deadly tools there is
still so much more to discover in rise
of the Tomb Raider and we can't wait for
you to experience it for yourself thank
you for joining us on woman vs lion
you